would you want a woman to do
what you're doing to mike
to your two sons would you want that
no okay
that's not funny but the honesty totally
caught me off guard
mike you need to run
mike is still refusing to end his
relationship with ximena even after the
cast and his friends practically beg him
to i know this kind of woman like ximena
and she's not gonna stop until
she completely destroys him and there is
nothing
left apparently her vagina's got voodoo
liver move on
how do you help a friend in a situation
like mike's i think you guys that are
close to him as his friends it is your
duty to make sure that you save this guy
we'll get into that plus what led to
ximena walking off the tell-off set
twice
and what's next for the couple now that
the season is over
i just want to say that i'm my own man i
can make my own decisions
i still want to go to grantham and see
what happens
oh let's talk about it
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia part
two of the tell-all was good
before we get into mike and ximena there
are some other quick standout moments
that i have to show you
like memphis unapologetically laughing
while hoshon robinson is questioning
ella about cheating on johnny
so you had a guy
fly in
to spend your birthday with you it was
somebody that you had met
on a on a previous dating site
and then you guys kept in touch about
just the birthday thing
okay she's a whole mood
okay also it looks like gino was out
here lying again
about the nude photos of jasmine that he
sent to his ex
now he's saying he sent it by a mistake
i didn't send a nude photo on purpose to
her
and it was
one that accidentally sent
gino then says he only sent one topless
photo of jasmine but she says he sent
three i mean you know
you stand at different times three
different
topless pictures
she said you sent three photos that were
nude
that were nude
no no no no
no no no it was only one partial nude
pick raise your hand if you believe that
and guess what cast member is walking
around during the tell-all
giving couples advice to everyone as an
ex-pastor i have counseled a lot of
couples yep good old ben
and kim is not having it i think
you know you really can't get to that
point of true intimacy where you're just
like you are boyfriend and girlfriend
until you get that face to face and then
everything behind you
has just got to go like you can't bring
it up it's in the past i'm sorry ben's
telling us all about our relationships
like his is so perfect
don't stay up here and be all pastory
and acting like
you can just judge every single one of
us but you better take some of that
judgment on yourself
told you
kim said uh-uh don't sit up here and be
all pastory don't sit up here
and be all pastory you know one of the
most interesting parts about these
tell-alls is watching the cast members
share their opinions on other couples
it is proof that the advice we give is
the exact same advice we need to hear
ourselves because ben said this to kim
i think
you know you really can't get to that
point of true intimacy where you're just
like you are boyfriend and girlfriend
until you get that face to face when he
was ready to marry mahogany before he
even confirmed she was a real person
mahogany are you and benjamin back
together as boyfriend and girlfriend
speaking of ben and mahogany these two
are back together
what the hell
yes and they are talking about getting
married next year
one year from now
we'll be back here in this park yes as
husband and wife
oh my gosh baby that's my prediction
we'll see what happens she is running
game on you so bad says oh i'm gonna get
married in a year i i hope i pray for
you i hope it works you know what i'm
saying yeah well you probably you had so
much criticism from my relationship and
for everybody on here yeah we all and
yours is the worst one here
we also learned that ben gave mahogany a
thousand dollars before they met in
person did you send her a thousand but i
did yes okay
lord
and jasmine doesn't sugarcoat how she
feels about ben's behavior this season
ben she letting you know before you
arrived to peru that she was no longer
interested and you kind of
chasing her and knowing that she's so
young and i don't know but it gives me
like pervert bite
there are a number of people who would
agree
all right i know that took a minute but
those were some key moments that i had
to show you and oh yeah i see that some
of you want another glimpse of kim's son
jamal so here you go you are welcome
now let's get into the cast reacting to
ximena using mike for money
we were able to work it out
and today we're back together on part
one of the tell-all we learned that
ximena and mike are back together after
their nasty breakup and on part two
ximena confirms that they are indeed
boyfriend and girlfriend but she admits
she is still not in love with him
ximena says she's giving the
relationship another shot to see if mike
has really changed he is planning on
taking her on a trip to cartagena a
beautiful city off columbia's coast
and that's where she says she'll
determine whether she'll move forward
with him so yes after all the drama she
is about to get a free vacation courtesy
of you know who
she's not in love with you
when ximena sees that mike is upset
about her confession that she's not in
love with him she reassures him that she
loves him a lot but she just needs some
time
time for what he's paying all of her
bills what is he
what do you need time for he's been
there already he's proved to you what a
good person he is
to your children he supports you
what more can you want
i mean this is a good dude and my heart
is breaking for him right now yes
look at mike smirking he's sad but at
the same time he seems to be loving all
the compliments and backup he's
receiving from the cast right now it's
good
might want to work on that you've been
taking care of this lady with her kids
for some time
now she's still telling you today that
she didn't love you
you need to just get out from this
the confusion mike is feeling is written
all over his face at this point it looks
like it hurts
mikey in all this time have you continue
helping her financially and if your
answer is yes like to what extent
after mike confirms to the cast that
he's been paying for ximena's rent and
food they react and they don't hold back
but she has to decide if she loves you
or not that's crazy
she's basically taking care of her
completely i'm sorry bro
okay
let's bring some balance into this
we can't forget that mike has chosen to
take care of ximena he's basically
taking care of her completely i'm sorry
bro so even if you disagree with her
behavior let's not approach it as if
he's the victim here
he chose
ximena to a lot of people it seems like
you're just in this relationship with
mike for the money
you went around your apartment and
showed everything he bought for you and
then that last night you couldn't even
let him stay in the apartment that he
pays for you
damn
mike i'm sorry i'm sorry you deserve so
much better than that is it just me or
is this a really vocal cast
they are saying how they feel with no
filter
things take a turn for the worse when
mike's friend and 90 day mvps nelsie and
john come out
mike is dreading seeing them because
apparently ximena hates nelsie
yes
and mike fears his friends will mess up
the progress he's made with ximena
basically he doesn't want them to be
blockers
excuse my language
how do you see their relationship
just the same way everybody sees her
she's just with him because of her money
he is buying her love why are you with
mike
why are you with mike
if something happens to you mike like
god forbid knock on wood
there's an accident you can't provide
you can't work
you're gone bro you're never gonna hear
from her again that right there hit home
for mike because he looks at ximena and
asks is that true ximena is that true
like if something happened to me you
would just leave mike and of course she
says no i mean mike did you really think
she would say yes ximena you can't even
tolerate his
isn't that crazy oh my god oh no she
just admitted it wow oh wow usman then
pops a question which leads to mike's
friend john making a very blunt
statement but it's also what we've all
been thinking does that lady i mean did
she use voodoo on you because like yeah
she didn't love me she said apparently
her vagina's got voodoo
nelsie brings up how mike is learning
spanish for ximena but she's not even
trying to learn english
and that is so good of you to try so
hard and try so much but this she's just
not worth it she's just not she do not
you will find somebody that will love
you the right way will be okay with you
farting once in a while not while
kissing
um i think you guys that are close to
him as his friends it is your duty to
make sure that you save this guy let's
get real
do y'all agree with usman is it john and
nelsey's duty as mike's friends to save
him from ximena i think it's their duty
to let him know their honest thoughts
and to be there when he falls but
i don't think it's their duty to
actively try to save him because
news flash mike doesn't want to be saved
right now
joanne in the comments says in part
quote i feel bad for everyone involved
she then goes on to say quote why would
he want to be with her when she clearly
doesn't love him
i don't have that answer but i think
mike wants what he wants so bad that
he's willing to risk it all whenever i
want something really bad i try to step
back and see if the desire is coming
from a healthy place i wanted to see
what happens if it makes me feel anxious
and constrained more than likely i know
that it's coming from an unhealthy place
and that thing i want is probably not
even good for me porque persona
because she hates talking to me because
i put her on the spot i know this kind
of woman like ximena and she's not gonna
stop until
she completely destroys him and there is
nothing
left mike wasn't hearing any of that he
was freaking out because ximena walked
off
and someone told her
and once she came back it didn't take
long for her to walk off again
do not tell me to shut up
then just
leave
so then i leave
no she sit down and go look with her
after nelsie makes her exit ximena
finally returns with an outfit change
and mike tells her what he needs moving
forward in this relationship
i still want to go to cartagena with you
and just see how things work
but
can you
please be more understanding and
actually change
would you want a woman to do
what you're doing to mike
to your two sons would you want that
no okay
so why do it to mike
she didn't answer
mike ignores that major red flag
but you know what he's got to learn this
himself and ask ximena if she could take
learning english seriously
i'll help you
yo how are you
after the tell-all wraps everyone goes
their separate ways
and mike facetimes ximena and she tells
him that they're going to get married
and prove everyone wrong
i guess she's talking about us soon
[Music]
[Music]
you know my parents always told me a
hard head makes a soft behind
time will tell if the rumors are true
ximena has already moved on from mike
either way i wish those two the best
all right that does it for season 5 of
before the 90 days i'll be back next
week with a recap of the premiere
episode of 90 day fiance's ninth season
[Music]
90 day has turned sexy
alright fans fam make sure you stick
with e.t because we are covering it all
i will see you next time
[Music]